this line counted two of the three goals on the
road trip as both hurdle and zland scored loose
puck in front and Demco with a nice save off zland
who got a grade A Chance there off the rebound
chance for Vancouver drop pass for Hughes right
on him Zaden Puck stays into Patterson now from
the point he'll give it up to blasic bumps it off
the boards but doesn't get it out and Hughes goes
right back to work Pon loading up the one-time
Brock besser and he scores a bullet by Vancouver's
number six besser it's one- nothing so the Sharks
able to get it Mark Edward blasic but he doesn't
get everything out on the back hand that's a tough
clear in this day's NHL guys are able to knock
down pucks and then is a rocket as Mark ever vasic
tries to come out and block it I think what he
does he provides the screen goes by him short side
and goes to the back of the net heck of a shot
Miller snaps it back hard now it's fired in on a
set play and he scores what a play by
the kaks and JT Miller makes it two to
nothing it's a long dump in as you're going to see
M now just take off he's inished on the side right
there he's just going to take off gets after it
and then beats Capo kakin and backand up high I
like this play cuz it's smart it's also knowing as
David quo talked about they might be predictable
to each other and not to the defense really
nicely executed play by the Vancouver kucks
you know Randy you were supposed to argue my
point there at the end I don't I guess maybe
you've made it before and I agree glass with a
backhander just miss dumps it out front here's
Kyle Burrows and Demco makes the P save Quinn
Hughes over to the right side Herona to Hughes
he'll load up pivot away from zido got a bit of it
with his stick now back for laferty laferty gives
for heroni heroni for Hughes lots of movement
off the puck and they score again Quinn Hughes
risting it through three nothing Vancouver in the
first eight minutes as quen Hughes gets the puck
up high he's going to be able to dance the line
and you don't really know what he's doing you
don't really know how to shut him down and as he
gets his own lane with the terrific job in front
this might have been a deflected for sure as we
look at it coming in there's so much traffic look
two Vancouver Canucks they're in Vancouver and
they're helping out as well with development of
players good for check by eckan but Hughes is
able to break through now Miller waiting for
help he'll take the shot the glove saved by Papo
Kenan here's Ryan Carpenter for the Sharks and
a safe for Demco his career against the Sharks
Bater Demco eight and0 another stop and off the
rebound Javan Smith with as good a look as the
sharks have had in this period Hughes right now
leads all NHL defenseman in scoring his brother
Jack started today leading the NHL in points
and his other brother Luke leading all rookie
defenseman until yesterday he was second going
into today they're all having great starts and
a goal for Bessel as he bats it out of the air
and the kucks are three for three on their power
play watch the player movement here in front of
the net his m is there he's going to roll out
and the chance as the man drives down towards
the net and besser just comes straight down the
middle everybody's looking at the puck carrier it
goes from one side up high down low and then the
man driving the net now good stick Pops in the
air baby and zerin with some speed into the
con Zone backs in their defenseman but Tyler
Meers with that Long Reach able to pick it away
off zland now flipped ahead by kzco to pon pon
drops it the pass the shot the goal by Elia
mckv and the kucks score a minute three into
period two it's 5 nothing as the entry into the
Zone sharks don't get back and pick up the right
man which was Carson Susi he jumps in and he
is terrific vision and you're in scramble mode
after that if you don't get back and and have
the right numbers coming back or picking up
the right guy now you're all facing the park and
kzco the dangle the shot into traffic pops back
out to leank he'll send it off the board for
ziden but it's gathered back in Freedman for
kzco he's bumped but peton gives it back to
him here's Keno skates in shoots and scores
Andre kuzmenko adds to to the onslaught and
it's 6 nothing Vancouver a drive to the net
you always want guys driveing the net kzco
comes in fires the puck and then gives the
thigh to kokak and and watch his head there
his MCO just keeps going straight as you can
see it was a total accident didn't mean to
do it they wanted to make sure was okay out
comes zerland to serve the extra minor for
cunan almost picked that off for a chance
and we're back to Five On Five laery Oh score
he tried to wrap it around it pinballed in I
believe off Ferraro and it's 7 nothing yeah
on this one he uses a speed look how he gets
the Inside Edge he's on that interesting he's
on the outside skatee and he's really working
that Inside Edge of the outside skate the
right skate and he's able to get Le Bank as
H comes out of the box looking for the tip
in front for was sterm but it wasn't there
shks were looking for a penalty on that glove
because they thought he closed his hand on the
PO look out here here's Quin Hugh with laery
and sudor and he scores que is sooner fifth
point of the game for Quinn Hughes and it's
ain't nothing again timing coming out of the
Penalty Box and now you've got a three onone and
it's just perfectly time pass Suter opens up for
theiler checked by cunan Carson Susi now
he'll get it back and a one timer sliding
across Blackwood but it snuck through
and Anthony boiler gets a goal in his
five 100th game to make it nine for
the Canucks power play continues to
roll looked like McKenzie had got over there
in time when a when a pass goes through like
that where it goes Point down off to the flank
where exactly where bili was standing and now
P Suter who as one of the nine goals Garland and
off the glove Blackwood he'll get a save for that
Garland again boiler scores and now we're into
double digits as Anthony boiler has his second
tonight sharks have possession of this this is
one that should get out but the four check of
the Canucks it doesn't stop it stays on they win
the battle for the puck boiler beautiful shot over
the shoulder and the kucks had the advantage
that their feet were moving unless you get the
puck couple feet elevated it's not going in thanks
to Thatcher demos athleticism Demco 64 192 listed
as that's a that's a gym save right there that's
see a guy working on his flexibility sand scores
and there will be no shut out although Demco is
claiming he was interfered [Applause] with give
the Sharks fans credit it may be an ironic cheer
but they are cheering nonetheless let's check it
out coming through the crease that zadina
Zaden looked like he was bumped hav perused
all the out of town scores carefully Drew but
I would suspect that Quinn Hughes will be the
star of the night in the National Hockey League
this one comes to a merciful end for the sharks